became like the social commentary for
the kitchen it's not like I wrote
materials I would go up there and just
to [__] uh you know whatever look at
this [__] with these [__] shoes
on what your mother didn't get better
shoes and one day the guy in the library
was from Buffalo he killed his wife and
the mailman the mailman was his wife so
he killed the wife now man they're
getting like dirty [__] [__] I never
forget he came up to me one day and he
goes hey man here's a notebook she can
write your jokes notebook I got no
[__] notebook he goes you don't write
before you go up there I'm gonna go no
this [__] looked at me because
listen I'm gonna get out of here about
two years if I get out and you're not
doing stand-up I'm gonna hunt you down
and kill you
uh